Today’s 1 Minute Monday is
Be BETTER!
I get a lot of entrepreneurs who write in to me
and they say, “Evan, I wish I had more momentum
I wish I had more customers
I wish I had more money coming in.
That only happens
when you get better at what you do.
I look at my YouTube channel
and, you know, we’re coming up on 2 million views
I wish it was at 200 million views
I can get there by being better
And if you look at my channel
and you look at where I was 2 years ago
go look at some of the older videos
the videos now
are way better than they were 2 years ago
and that’s why the views may be
3, 5, 10, 20 as much.
But I still need to get better
and so do you.
If you’re not getting the results
that you want from your business
then you need to be better.
I want you to think about
3 things in the customer experience
from the product they’re buying
to the service they’re getting
to every single interaction they get with you
think of 3 things that you can make better
because you want every single time
a customer comes and talks to you
you want them leaving saying
“Wow! That was amazing.”
If you’re not there yet
then you need to be better.
Believe.